einen schönen abend zdf heute live hier
mit den aktuellen ereignissen aus berlin
denn nach einem langen abend und harten
verhandlungen sehen wir gerade die
bundeskanzlerin und die vertreter der
minister präsidenten und präsidentinnen
auf das pressekonferenz podium gehen
bundeskanzlerin an dass das anscheinend
ein ziemlich harter abend war die
höheren mal was sie zu sagen hat sie
machen uns auch mut denn langsam geht
zumindest im raum blickt die zahl der
neuinfektionen zurück und man muss sagen
gott sei dank haben wir auch weniger
menschen auf den intensivstationen zur
behandlung und da spricht alles dafür
dass die harten einschnitte die die
menschen in deutschland auf sich
genommen haben sich auszuzahlen beginnen
und dafür möchte ich von herzen danken
gleichwohl haben die ministerpräsidenten
und ich uns entschlossen uns nicht erst
am 25
januar wieder zu treffen und zu beraten
sondern bereits heute und dafür haben
wir einen wichtigen grund denn all
unsere bemühungen die ausbreitung des
virus einzudämmen droht eine ernsthafte
gefahr die wir heute klarer sehen als
wir das am 5 januar konnten und das ist
die mutation des virus wie sie vor allem
aber nicht nur in großbritannien und
irland aufgetaucht ist warum liegt darin
eine solche gefahr weil die bisherigen
epidemiologischen erkenntnisse daran
hebt darauf hindeuten dass dieses
mutierte virus sehr viel ansteckender
ist und das ist eine hauptursache für
den gewaltigen anstieg der infektionen
sowohl in großbritannien als auch in
irland ist bei uns ist dieses mutierte
virus nachgewiesen worden allerdings
wissen wir nicht ganz genau in welcher
menge aber einzelne fälle sind bekannt
die wissenschaftler sagen uns dass es
noch nicht dominant ist
noch ist gewissermaßen zeit die ganze
gefährlichkeit auch einzudämmen und
es wäre natürlich vollkommen falsch
daraus zu schließen dass wir dann auch
noch wirklich alle zeit der welt hätten
um zu handeln
wir müssen jetzt handeln und das hat
mich jedenfalls aber auch uns alle
bei den beratungen heute bewegt jetzt
ist die zeit um der gefahr gehen diese
mutierten virus steckt vorzubeugen es
geht also um vorsorge und wenn sich die
mutation bei uns schon ausgebreitet
hätte dann könnten sich die
infektionszahlen das ist ja was wir in
anderen ländern gesehen haben exklusiv
erhöhen
mit der folge dass dann auch unsere
krankenhäuser in eine schwer zu
beherrschende lage geraten würden
deshalb haben wir heute noch einmal
beraten und auch zusätzliche maßnahmen
und einschränkungen beschlossen um den
rückgang der infektionszahlen in
deutschland noch einmal deutlich zu
beschleunigen
darin geht es wir wissen wenn die
infektionszahlen gering sind hat auch
das mutierte virus wenig chancen sich
weiter auszubreiten
und deshalb setzen wir auf dem weg den
wir gerade haben sinkende
infektionszahlen vor diesen weg
beschleunigen durch zusätzliche
maßnahmen das heißt also wir tun das aus
vorsorge für unser land
aus vorsorge für die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber eben auch
aus vorsorge für die wirtschaft und die
arbeitswelt die unter einer
explosionsartigen anstieg dann doch sehr
stark leiden würde
zu den beschlüssen im einzelnen bin ich
hier hervorheben dass wir uns zuerst
einmal darauf geeinigt haben dass wir
alle maßnahmen die bis zum 31 januar
befristet waren bis zum 14 februar
verlängern müssen
das ist natürlich ein gewaltiger schritt
und wir wissen auch was das für die
bürgerinnen
bürger aber auch für andere bedeutet
zweiter bleibt es bei der auch der
privaten zusammenkünfte die erlaubt sind
also ein haus stand und mit einer
weiteren nicht zum hausstand gehörenden
personen
wir weisen aber daraus darauf hin dass
es infektion logisch dann am besten ist
wenn die zahl der personen mit denen man
sich trifft eine kleine ist und
möglichst konstant ist damit sozusagen
nicht immer wieder kontakte und
infektionsketten entstehen können
wir erweitern die pflicht zum tragen von
medizinischen masken also op masken oder
auch masken von der qualität sp2 oder
kein 95 n95 um eine höhere schutzwirkung
zu haben das gilt für die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel und für die geschäfte
verbindliche pflicht also das zu tragen
und generell wird auch in situationen wo
ein engerer oder längerer kontakt ist zu
anderen personen die nutzung
medizinischer masken angeraten
das ziel von uns ist dem die kontakte im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr so zu
reduzieren dass das theater ist
aufkommen deutlich zurückgeht dass in
der regel die abstände gewahrt werden
können und wie wollen wir dieses ziel
erreichen einmal durch weitgehende
nutzung von home office möglichkeiten
hier sind wir weit hinter den werten die
wir im
märz hatten des vergangenen jahres
zurück indem wir das alles tun um das
fahrgastaufkommen zu entfernen den
stoßzeiten des berufs und schülerverkehr
und eben ergänzend die pflicht zum
tragen medizinischer masten
wir haben lange gerungen um das was im
bereich kinder und schule notwendig ist
wir alle wissen dass es unglaubliche
einschränkungen mit sich bringt für die
betroffenen kinder für die betroffenen
eltern aber es gibt ernstzunehmende
hinweise dass die mutation w 11 752
virus sich auch stärker unter kinder und
jugendlichen verbreitet als das bei den
bisherigen virus der fall ist und diese
hinweise müssen wir ernst nehmen und
deshalb verweisen wir noch einmal auf
den beschluss vom 13
dezember 2020 wir müssen ihnen bis zum
14 februar 2020 verlängern
und wir müssen auf eine restriktive
umsetzung dieses beschlusses dringen
darauf haben wir uns auch gar nicht nach
langer diskussionen
danach bleiben die schulen grundsätzlich
geschlossen beziehungsweise die
präsenzpflicht bleibt ausgesetzt und in
kindertagesstätten wird analog verfahren
wir wissen was die erzieherinnen und
lehrer leisten und sagen deshalb dreimal
deutlich dass wir ihnen danken für das
was sie in der bewältigung der pandemie
gerade bei den kindern und jugendlichen
leisten
wir kommen noch einmal zurück auf die
alten und pflegeheime wir haben ja in
den letzten tagen noch mal durch die
bereitschaft von 10.000
bundeswehrsoldaten zu helfen um die
testungen durchzuführen
auch noch mal einen praktischen schritt
getan und das war's für alten und
pflegeheime gilt gilt auch für die
einrichtungen von menschen mit
behinderungen das ist ganz wichtig weil
die rechtlich woanders verankert sind
und oft vergessen werden das wollen wir
ausdrücklich nicht sie sagen etwas zu
gottesdiensten in kirchen synagogen und
moscheen und die zusammenkünfte anderer
glaubensgemeinschaften sie sind nur
unter strikten voraussetzungen gestattet
abstand halten maske auch medizinische
maske tragen
untersagung des gemeinde gesangs
zusammenkünfte und mehr als zehn
teilnehmern sind beim zuständigen
ordnungsamt spätestens zwei werktage
zuvor anzuzeigen
sofern es sich schon generelle
absprachen mit der religionsgemeinschaft
mit bestimmten behörden geht zentraler
punkt heute in unseren diskussionen war
neben schule und kita noch einmal das
arbeiten im home office
hier gehen wir jetzt rechtlich vor die
frage hat mir ja auch am fünften januar
schon diskutiert der minister für arbeit
und soziales wird eine verordnung
besuchte bis zum 15 märz erst bei mahler
lassen wonach arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber überall dort wo es möglich
ist den beschäftigten das arbeiten im
home office ermöglichen müssen sofern
die tätigkeiten das zu lassen
und wir gehen davon aus dass dadurch
kontakte am arbeitsort aber auch auf dem
weg zur arbeit reduziert werden und wir
bitten die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer diese angebote auch
wirklich zu nutzen da wo präsenz weiter
erforderlich ist wollen wir natürlich
auch einen möglichst guten schutz der
beschäftigten deshalb auch die belegung
von räumen reduzieren wo nicht
ausreichende abstände möglich sind
müssen medizinische masken getragen
werden und wir bitten die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber darauf
hinzuwirken dass der stern des
fahrgastaufkommens im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr auch anfangs und
endzeiten der arbeit variiert werden
damit wir die digitalisierung der sehr
viel mit dem home office zu tun hat
voranbringen werden noch einmal
besondere abschreibe möglichkeiten
geschaffen
ich glaube das ist ein guter schritt
auch als anreiz und das lohnt sich ja
auch für die kommende zeit
wir gehen auf ein dass die instanz von
50 wie wir sie uns ja vorgenommen haben
in vielen landkreisen nicht erreicht
wird und dass deshalb weiterhin über die
allgemeinen regeln hinaus gehende
umfangreiche lokale und regionale
maßnahmen dort getroffen werden können
wo eben diese instanz noch nicht
erreicht wird
damit wir sozusagen langsam uns dann in
geleitzug auch in richtung der 50 pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tage als
incidents bewegen können
wir haben dann noch mal lange über das
impfen gesprochen
hier sind wir natürlich von der
verlässlichkeit der produzenten abhängig
wir haben das jetzt alle erlebt dass
kaiser plötzlich die fisch die
lieferungen verändert hat das ist von
großen auswirkungen für die gesamte
logistik der länder und wir haben uns
miteinander verabredet dass wir von
unserer seite alles tun wollen um
erstmal bis zum ende des sommers jedem
bürger ins angebot zu machen sind dabei
natürlich aber abhängig davon dass die
impfdosen sondern auch wirklich zur
verfügung gestellt werden wollen aber
von unserer seite aus werden wir alles
tun und wir haben uns mit der
sequenzierung beschäftigt denn wir
erwarten jetzt dass wir doch mehr
informationen bekommen über dieses
mutierte virus und der bund wird das
anfang februar hier eine erste
auswertung vorliegen die experten
insbesondere wasser trotzdem haben uns
gestern gesagt dass in zwei bis drei
wochen eine gute chance besteht hier
eine bessere quantitative analyse zu
bekommen wären noch einmal darüber
gesprochen wenn wir eine eröffnungs
strategie miteinander vereinbar
das ist dann natürlich notwendig ist die
wiedererlangt und aufrechterhaltung der
kontrolle über das infektionsgeschehen
zu haben
und das heißt dass wir eine vollständige
kontakt nachverfolgung garantieren
können und das mist bedeutet dass die
gesundheitsämter personell und
organisatorisch noch verstärkt werden
müssen und diese zeit die wir jetzt
haben bis zum 15 februar die müssen wir
nutzen um dafür die voraussetzungen zu
schaffen
dazu soll das system noch sommers
eingesetzt werden bzw schnittstellen
geschaffen werden damit eine bundesweite
kommunikation und eine einfachere
kontakt nach verfolgung möglich ist ein
letztes wort von meiner seite zu dem
thema
europa wir werden am donnerstag einen
europäischen rat als video konferenz
haben wo wir uns neben der impfung auch
mit dem thema mutation mit beschäftigen
werden und es ist vollkommen klar und
von vielen hier heutige auch gesagt von
den von den ministerpräsidenten
deutschlands ist umgeben von vielen
ländern und wir können hier tun und
lassen was wir wollen
wir werden keinen erfolg haben wenn
nicht andere synchronen auch daran
arbeiten
ich weiß dass nachbarländer wie dänemark
und niederlande sich heute auch damit
beschäftigt haben maßnahmen zu
verstärken
aber wir müssen sicherstellen dass hier
wirklich alle unsere nachbarländer in
die gleiche richtung arbeiten wenn das
nicht der fall ist müssen wir eben auch
vorkehrungen treffen bei einreise fragen
weil wir uns das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger hier leisten und was wir ihnen
auferlegen natürlich nicht sozusagen
wieder zunichte machen lassen dürfen
indem wir das virus dann immer wieder
eintragen und das ist auch ein großes
thema und das ruft nach einheitlichen
europäischen vorgehen das bezieht sich
nicht nur auf die eu sondern zum
beispiel auch auf nachbarländer wie die
schweiz die ja nicht zur europäischen
das waren im wesentlichen unsere
beschlüsse ist lange gedauert ich glaube
es hat sich gelohnt
es ist hart was ihr jetzt den menschen
noch einmal zumuten müssen aber das
vorsorgeprinzip hat für uns vorrang und
den müssen wir jetzt auch rechnung
tragen und den haben wir heute auch
rechnung getragen
ja es gibt tatsächlich hoffnung und eine
positive perspektive und nicht nur durch
das impfen das ja nur noch durch alle
bundesländer engagiert umgesetzt wird
und wir sehr viel positive resonanz auch
von den geimpften bekommen
für diese umsetzung sondern auch durch
unsere letzten beschlüsse die er gezeigt
haben dass es etwas bringt sich immer
wieder miteinander zu verabreden
maßnahmen gemeinsam umzusetzen
die zahlen gehen nach unten sie gehen in
die richtige richtung und das alles ist
eine gute ausgangslage
und trotzdem bleibt die lage ernst und
ich habe für alle verständnis die jetzt
auch vielleicht dieser pressekonferenz
folgen und sich fragen da muss es dann
so sein muss es dann wirklich sein dass
maßnahmen verlängert werden neue
maßnahmen miteinander verabredet werden
wenn es doch eine positive tendenz gibt
und ich habe auch verständnis dafür wenn
viele vielleicht einfach nur auch müde
und erschöpft sind nach diesen langen
corona monaten und auch sagen man kann
es kaum noch hören und man will jetzt
einfach auch über andere dinge mal regen
zu können und und andere möglichkeiten
auch wiedersehen für das private leben
und für die familie ich habe für alters
verständnis und doch kann man ja dinge
nicht wegdiskutieren und probleme und
risiken die da sind wir hatten am montag
eine beratung mit acht experten acht
experten aus den unterschiedlichsten
wissenschaftsbereichen haben uns
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten beraten zu haben
noch mal in ihrer einschätzung zur
aktuellen lage abgegeben wo stehen wir
was haben wir erreicht was kommt
gegebenenfalls auf und fuhren ohne
ausnahme haben alle bestätigt wir sind
gemeinsam auf dem richtigen weg es sind
die richtigen maßnahmen es gibt erfolge
aber man muss das ernst nehmen was um
uns herum ja schon wirklich in aller
dramatik auch zu sehen ist an neuen
infektionsgeschehen und dieses mutierte
wie
was machten an ländergrenzen nicht halt
das ist da oder es wird auch noch
verstärkt zu uns kommen und wir müssen
uns auf diese situation genau jetzt
vorbereiten nicht nächste woche nicht
nächsten monat sondern genau jetzt
müssen wir uns darauf vorbereiten gerade
weil wir ja gemeinsame erfolge auch
nicht verspielen wollen gemeinsame
entlastung die wir auch schrittweise
sehen in unseren krankenhäusern
genau darum geht es an dieser stelle
jetzt anzusetzen
und es ist nun mal so wir können von
seiten der politik in vielen bereichen
auch rahmenbedingungen nur
rahmenbedingungen sich an der stelle
aufsetzen
wir können dinge selbst in die hand
nehmen und gut organisieren nochmal wie
im bereich des impfens wir können
verantwortungsvoll mit dingen umgehen
und möglichkeiten wirklich mit in aller
besonnenheit und
verantwortungsbewusstsein und voller an
verantwortungsbewusstsein auch umsetzen
wie im bereich der schule wir haben im
dezember wir haben im januar zum bereich
zu diesen sensiblen auch sozial
politisch sensiblen themenfeld der
schule etwas geschlossen und man kann
sagen dass die länder ja wirklich
restriktiv auch bisher schon damit
umgegangen sind das nur in absoluten
ausnahmefällen ja präsenzunterricht auch
unter direkten unter diversen maßnahmen
werden die dann begleitend beschlossen
werden umgesetzt wird die allermeisten
schulen sind geschlossen das ist ganz
klar anhand der infektionszahlen in
einen ans einzelnen bundesländern gibt
es da auch kaum einen anderen spielraum
also insofern gehen alle bisher damit
verantwortungsvoll um und werden es auch
weiterhin tun aber wir sind auch nach
wie vor angewiesen auf unterstützung und
solidarität sowie in den letzten monaten
wir haben es miteinander gekonnt wir
haben es miteinander gelernt was geht im
frühjahr im sommer haben wir gemeinsam
durch die rahmenbedingungen die die
politik gesetzt hat und durch
eigenverantwortliches besonders handeln
haben wir gemeinsam viel erreicht und
darauf kommt es jetzt wieder an das
gemeinsam so fortzuführen und es ist
eigentlich auch relativ simpel und
natürlich in der umsetzung trotzdem
anstrengend und bedrückend aber wenn
dieses virus glücklicherweise doppelt so
ansteckend ist wie das was wir bisher
haben an corinna virus wenn es
aggressiver ist dann bedeutet das für
uns eben auch dass wir unsere bemühungen
im kampf gegen dieses virus verdoppeln
müssen und das heißt dann eben auch halb
soviel begegnung halb soviel aktivitäten
halb soviel einkäufe halb so viele
fahrten ins büro halb so viele kontakte
und auch was wir als schwerpunkt der in
dieser mpk auch beschlossen haben
deutlich weniger halb soviel kontakte im
büro weniger arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer im büro glaube dass es auch
wichtig war dass das auch öffentlich
wahrgenommen wird wir gucken nicht nur
in die einrichtung wir gucken nicht nur
auf die privaten kontakte oder auf diese
sensiblen bereiche wie schule theater
sport sondern wir gucken auch auf die
anderen bereiche und dort wo es noch
möglichkeiten gibt gemeinsam gegen
dieses virus vorzugehen wollen und
werden wir auf diese möglichkeiten
nutzen deswegen waren das wichtige
verabredung gehen wir auch zum thema
home office getroffen haben also aus den
erfahrungen des frühjahrs lärm dieser
erfahrung und diese möglichkeiten die
wir miteinander gesehen haben
fortzuführen jetzt schon eben weiter auf
diesen guten weg zu bleiben
darauf kommt dass an und insofern kann
ich dann war anschließen es hört sich
vielleicht erst mal nach nicht großartig
neuen beschlüssen an ich glaube die sind
auch gar nicht nötig denn dass wir die
bisherigen maßnahmen verlängern bis zum
14 ist ja auch schon inhaltlich ein
wichtiger schritt den wir miteinander
verabreden konnten in der pandemie
bekämpfung das kommt jetzt eben auch
noch darauf dass zu das öffentliche
leben zu reduzieren im bereich der
arbeitsstätten des wirtschaftslebens die
maske hat noch mal einen anderen
stellenwert auch bekommen indem wir auch
ganz klar qualitätsanforderungen an das
maske tragen miteinander formulieren
kontakte natürlich zu vermeiden die
bundeskanzlerin hat schon gesagt bleibt
nach wie vor das a und o
also insofern denke ich nach wie vor
eine situation bei der man sich nicht
zurücklehnen kann bei der man aber auch
nicht mutlos sein muss mit dem was wir
bisher erreicht haben sondern
wir aus gutem gewissen sagen können wir
können darauf aufbauen und anknüpfen und
wir können gemeinsam auch weiterhin viel
erreichen und nicht nur das bisher
bekannte im rahmen der pandemie
bekämpfung in den griff zu bekommen
sondern auch das neue das jetzt
möglicherweise auf uns zukommt herr
ministerpräsident
ja man ist damit herr bundeskanzler
werden ist eher gemischte gefühlslage in
deutschland und zwar mehrfach gemischt
zum einen einmal ein herzliches
dankeschön dafür wie die menschen ist in
überragender zahl so großartig alles
mitmachen man muss das gemälde der neue
report kapitulieren was seit monaten die
menschen an einschränkungen hinnehmen
und zwar nicht nur um sich zu schützen
sondern auch viele viele andere nötig
mir immer wieder ganz großen respekt
deswegen danke dafür aber alles in
gestresst und auch unglaublich viele
genervt und es geht wirklich an die
substanz langsam auch bei vielen
existenzen
das ist die mission gefühlslage in die
menschen wollen helfen
sie sind auch bereit dazu aber wie
gesagt alle sind jetzt doch in einer
schwierigen situation
zweitens gemischte gefühlslage hoffnung
etwas hoffnung weil die zahlen doch
tatsächlich runtergehen über all das ist
positiv das heißt der lok dann wird
natürlich also die maßnahme beschlossen
wurden wirken
das ist positiv aber auch hier wieder
gemischte gefühlslage es ist deswegen
keine entwarnung da sondern eine
mögliche mutation stellt uns vor eine
völlig neue herausforderung und viele
sind auch besorgt sogar deswegen ist
auch die entscheidungen heute im grunde
genommen eine gemischte
entscheidungslage zum einen einmal wir
dürfen auf keinen fall abbrechen
es wäre ein schwerer fehler gewesen
jetzt aufzuhören weil wir sonst einen
jojo effekt hätten bieten übrigens viele
partner länder um uns herum haben der
dann immer noch härteren lockt dann
bedeutet deswegen frühzeitig die
therapie abzubrechen wäre ein fehler
und umgekehrt an einigen stellen aber
konsequenter werden wie die
bundeskanzlerin sagte als vorsorge
vor dieser herausforderung die keiner
darf sich täuschen
ein mutiertes virus sich schneller
verbreitet ist nicht nur hoch gefährlich
sondern auch wahrscheinlich dass es sich
stärker verbreitet ein lockdown bremst
die verbleibe deswegen ist unsere
aufgabe jetzt nicht erst zu reagieren
wenn das kind in den brunnen gefallen
ist sondern zu verhindern dass selbst
bei einem virus im land einem
aggressiveren dass die verbreitung
stattfindet was woanders erlebt haben
und das macht es auch kommunikativ gar
nicht so einfach deswegen heute auch die
beschlüsse zweigeteilt zum einen das
verlängern bis 14 februar ich glaube das
war vorher auch relativ unstrittig und
an einigen stellen noch mehr konsequenz
wäre vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
drin gewesen
wir haben ja heute auch fast elf stunden
diskutiert trotzdem kann man sagen ist
viel erreicht worden was mich jetzt
freut und ich sage es jetzt auch mal für
unseren freistaat bayern
wie hat mir mit einigen anderen länder
zusammen ohnehin schon ein sehr hohes
sicherheitslevel erreicht wir haben
ausgangs beschränkungen wir haben wir
wahllos mobilitäts begrenzungen
doppelter weise nicht nur hinaus bewegen
aus einem hotspot sondern auch
vertretungen gerade bei touristischen
fragen und dass ich ein gutes signal für
eine verstärkte masken pflicht für alle
die fragen wir haben seit gestern auch
eine fb2 oder vergleichbare ersten
pflicht in bayern
da würde musste interessiert sein die
kann nur eines sagen wird das virus
gefährlicher muss die maske besser
werden ganz einfach das ist auch eine
der vorsorgemaßnahmen und die es jetzt
geht dann halte ich das für absolut
notwendig zu machen und damit im spnv
zum teil aber auch am arbeitsplatz eine
höhere sicherheit zu haben beim handel
ich bin dankbar auch dass die
bundeskanzlerin selbst sehr in die bütt
gestiegen ist beim thema schule und kita
das war das kann man schon sagen dann
will der umstrittenste porsche und ich
habe volles verständnis will ich
ausdrücklich sagen schule und kita ist
der absolut sensibelste punkt warum weil
wir natürlich dort am stärksten mit die
kollateral herausforderungen spüren für
familien für kinder
für die frage der betreuung deswegen ist
es nicht etwas so dass man da mit einem
federstrich das ganze angeht aber wir
haben aus vielen beratungen und
empfehlungen und internationalen
vergleichen eben erlebt dass schule und
kita eben auch ein pandemie verbreitung
in einigen ländern sogar beschleunigung
war so bleibt auch da einfach vorsicht
der bessere weg
und deswegen ist das verlängern der des
distanz unterrichtes auf der einen seite
unter notbetreuung auch grafik etat
glaube ich absolut sinnvoll und am ende
war es dann so dass auch die große
mehrzahl auch der flächenländer und auch
viele andere diesen weg mitgehen werden
ich halte es für richtig und bin auch
dankbar wir müssen halt daran arbeiten
dass wir im laufe des schuljahres viele
es vernünftig aufholen
ohne eltern und schüler zusätzlich unter
leistungsstress zu setzen
das ist ohne ihn ein stressiges jahr
einsatz noch ganz kurz zum thema office
auch da haben einen ganz guten
kompromiss gefunden natürlich brauchen
wir mehr oder fürs wo immer es geht muss
home office her ohne dabei die
betriebliche praxis so kaputt zu machen
dass es für manche betriebe gar nicht
anders möglich ist deswegen auch hier
zeitliche begrenzung zunächst mal mit
einer mit einer stärkeren bindung aber
eben auch mit steuerlichen anreizen was
ganz wichtig ist um die attraktivität
von home office zu nutzen aber eben auch
home office plätze zu schaffen zu
fördern
also wir machen nicht nur eine strenge
vorgabe wir versuchen auch eine
initiative zu setzen
schlussbemerkung ich bin nach wie vor
fest überzeugt dass kroner überwindbare
das impfen ist die große hoffnung scania
und die langzeitstrategie übrigens alle
anderen über monate hinweg ständig
empfehlungen gemacht haben wie man dies
und jenes in einer langzeitstrategie
münden kann
es sind im grunde genommen gescheitert
im in wie im ausland die einzige ist das
impfen deswegen ist auch so wichtig für
die qualität aber für die versorgung mit
impfstoff zu sorgen und auch dafür zu
sorgen dass er rechtzeitig da ist viele
dinge können wir nicht selbst steuern
umso wichtiger ist aber an der sache
dran zu bleiben klar ist aber auch und
es geht noch mal zum ausgangspunkt
zurück
wir dürfen jetzt aber nicht nachlassen
die hoffnung auf im stoff darf nicht
dazu führen dass wir glauben das ganze
ist jetzt nicht mehr notwendig oder weil
die zahlen runter gehen
das falsch zu glauben das ganze ist
schon gelaufen ganz im gegenteil in der
zweiten welle eine pandemie die stimme
die gefährlichere geschichtlich pandemie
geschichtlich die zweite welle ist viel
gefährlicher
man hat sich daran gewöhnt na ja das
geht doch irgendwie vielleicht ist gar
nicht so schlimm
einige sind auch ein bisschen
achselzucken wenn sie sagen auch was die
todeszahlen betrifft was mich jetzt mal
erschüttert wenn ich höre ja jahre sind
auch vor allem ältere menschen
der wert des lebens bemisst sich nicht
am alter ist eine grundsatz ethische
frage die es uns auch immer wieder zu
rekapitulieren geld und deswegen auch
noch mal mein appell bitte weiter
mitmachen dabei bleiben das wirklich
ernst nehmen wir haben es uns nicht
leicht gemacht heute nicht nur die länge
der sitzung zeigt es auch die argumente
ausgetauscht wurden
da ging es an einigen stellen insgesamt
sehr vernünftig zu wenn ich das sagen
darf er aber es war ein von der
leidenschaft geprägt aber von der tiefen
sorge wie es weiter geben unserem land
das alles keine einfachen entscheidungen
und ich glaube wir haben am ende
verantwortungsvolles dann auf eine
gemeinsame strategie geeinigt die erste
frage kommt von jörg blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin
frau bundeskanzlerin ich glaube weil es
sehr viele menschen interessiert frage
zum bereich der schule
wie soll denn aus ihrer sicht der
ausgefallenen unterricht aufgeholt
werden es angesprochen worden
denken sie daran vielleicht ostern oder
sommerferien zu verkürzen und was halten
sie von dem vorschlag dass in diesem
schuljahr niemand durchfallen kann und
an die ministerpräsidenten nachdem sie
beide auch von einer leidenschaftlichen
debatte gesprochen haben war die
vielleicht schon ein bisschen vom
wahlkampf geprägt danke also wenn ich
auf die letzte frage die an die neben
ministerpräsidenten da noch mal
beantworten werden nochmal anknüpfen
darf ich glaube die war er von der frage
geprägt was kann man sozusagen eltern
und kindern zumuten
und was bedeutet dass auch an vielleicht
langfristigen schäden sorgen und so
weiter und auf der anderen seite das ist
besser jetzt die maßnahmen vom dezember
wirklich restriktiv umsetzen was daneben
heißt entweder geschlossene schulen oder
keine präsenzpflicht oder eben zu sagen
na ja ich muss doch gerade bei den
kleineren ein bisschen struktur mehr
strukturen bringen was sich ja gut
verstehen kann ich meine distanz lernen
ist nun wirklich für schüler in der
ersten klasse oder einer zweiten klasse
keine reale option oder eine große
belastung für die eltern und ich
persönlich glaube nur dass wir uns
wirklich dem vorsorge gedanken
verpflichtet fühlen müssen und dass
diese verpflichtung uns leiten sollte
und wir haben ja dann auch nach hartem
ringen ein kompromiss gefunden der im
grunde sicherstellt dass auch das was
wir den eltern angeboten haben 20 tage
mehr auch bezahlt in zusammenhang mit
der pandemie genutzt werden kann
natürlich muss betreuung sichergestellt
werden für die die auch wirklich
beruflich gebunden sind die wir alle
brauchen das ist auch klar
und insofern ist mir sozusagen das jetzt
recht und über die frage wie wird das
nachgeholt also das werden die länder in
ihrer kompetenz gut aushandeln ich
glaube dass da möchte ich mich auch gar
nicht einmischen ich weiß dass viele
eltern bewegt markus söder dazu eben
etwas gesagt das ist sicherlich nicht
das jahr in dem man jetzt alle test
arbeiten nach schreiben muss oder
ähnliches aber ich glaube da hab ich
überhaupt gar keinen zweifel dass alle
länder da einen guten weg finden wichtig
ist doch dass wir schnell auf die 50
kommen damit wir dann über öffnungen
reden können so lange wir so wie wir
jetzt sind sind haben wir keinen
spielraum weil wir wissen bekommen
sofort wie das exponentielle wachstum
und jetzt haben wir noch die mutation
dazu von der wir wissen dass sie sich
schnell ausbreiten kann
und umso wichtiger ist eine schnelle
eine schnelle erreichung dass wir wieder
die kontakte nachverfolgen können damit
wir diese mutierten viren aus den wehren
herausfinden das ist essentiell und
deshalb diese leidenschaftliche debatte
die sich aus meiner sicht aber auch
gelohnt hat so ein thema wahlkampf
ich glaube da gibt es bessere und
öffentlichkeitswirksamer foren als in
einer elfstündigen internen mpk und
allen vorgesprächen dann wahlkampf dazu
machen
das ist wirklich nicht der fall dass
davon unsere diskussion geprägt sind
sondern wirklich er von der sorge um die
weil ihr punkte wie machen wir es
bestmöglich und die schule ist dafür
wirklich ein gutes beispiel gestern in
der beratung auch mit den experten hat
das natürlich eine große rolle gespielt
alle fragen danach gibt es besondere
auffälligkeiten gibt es dinge auf die
wir besonders reagieren müssen und
natürlich sagen uns die experten auch
wieder ihr müsst euch damit
auseinandersetzen dass es natürlich auch
einen infektionsgeschehen gibt ausgehend
von den kindern von den schulen aber
wiederum auch keine besonders
besorgniserregend
so insofern fließen diese erkenntnisse
mit einem die beratung und wir wissen im
zusammenhang mit der kontakt reduzierung
die ebenso wichtig ist muss man die
schule mitdenken muss eben auf der
anderen seite auch sehen wie ist die
situation vor ort was kann man
vielleicht ermöglichen und die will es
noch einmal betonen ja mit den
grundsatzbeschlüssen von dezember und
januar einen rahmen mit einander
formuliert mit dem wir sehr gut und
verantwortungsvoll in den letzten
monaten umgegangen sind
dort wo schulen geöffnet werden machen
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten das auch sehr
besonnen eben aufgrund der zahlen vor
ort die das dann ermöglichen und auch
nur für wenige jahrgänge und im wechsel
unterricht und mit abstands und
hygieneregeln und mit masken pflicht das
muss man alles zusammen denken und
insofern finde ich auch auch in diesem
sensiblen bereich gerade wird es
deutlich wie wir uns sehr intensiv und
leidenschaftlich auch mit so einem punkt
auseinander setzen wo wir auch von
unterschiedlichster seite mit
anforderungen konfrontiert werden ob das
so oder so machen sollen
alles das spiegelt sich in den
stundenlangen diskussionen wieder und es
wird dann einen weg gefunden glaube ich
mit denen sehr gut alle länder auch
arbeiten können insgesamt ist eine zur
schule also müssen wir überlegen wie das
weitere schuljahr abläuft und zwar
sowohl um die bildungsqualität zu
erhalten auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite aber auch um das ganze
fair zu gestalten
das sind glaube ich wird sehr wichtig
sein aber in diesem jahr zu überlegen ob
beispiel schweiz beispielsweise
übertritt oder versetzung stattfindet ob
man eine freiwillige weitergehen oder
auch noch mal machen des schuljahres zum
beispiel nicht anrechnet dafür würde ich
sehr plädieren dass man klausuren
reduziert deutlich reduziert ein anderes
verfahren findet und vor allen dingen
die qualität der bildungsabschlüsse
gewährleistet also hier ist es ein ganz
großes anliegen dass ein signal an die
eltern und schüler kommt dass wir alles
unternehmen werden eine hohe
bildungsqualität zu halten ohne einen
zusätzlichen leistungsdruck zu machen
wer dann auch gerade für diejenigen die
in der in dem
distanz unterricht an mit
schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen haben dass
die nicht verloren gehen als ein klares
bildungs versprechen das zweite mit dem
wahlkampf in der villa sagt das ist dass
das überhaupt nicht vom wahlkampf
geprägt ist dann stimmt es sicher so
kleine linien konnte man ab und zu
erkennen aber das ist ansonsten glaube
ich war es schon sehr von der großen
gemeinschaftlichen ins auge einfach
getragen keiner macht sich das im moment
leicht nico fried süddeutsche dass man
der späten stunde an mir liegen aber ich
habe den qualitativen unterschied noch
nicht verstanden bei der schule der der
geltenden beschluss wird fortgeschrieben
herr müller sagt das wird schon noch
restriktiv gehandhabt
worin besteht denn jetzt eigentlich die
weiterentwicklung
doch nur darin dass sie den beschluss
nicht zurückgenommen haben oder worin
besteht das restriktivere und ein
kleiner zusatz bitte was ist mit dem
thema ausgangssperren das war mal im
gespräch findet sich jetzt aber nicht
also aus meiner sicht war es nie im
gespräch es gibt länder die machen
ausgangssperren es gibt länder die
machen keine ausgangssperren ist wir
hatten den vergangenen beschlüssen
gesagt dass ausgangssperren und 15
kilometer regelung eine möglichkeit sein
können insbesondere bei hohen instanzen
aber das hat jetzt in den letzten tagen
eigentlich keine rolle gespielt wir
haben heute nur in dem punkt 9 noch mal
gesagt dass länder die wo das da wurde
man auch unter 200 kommt nehmen wir mal
an man hat einen besonders exponierten
landkreis und alle anderen landkreise
sind schon bei 120 und einer dass bei
190 das dann ist in das belieben der
jeweiligen institution also des
landkreises gestellt ist ob er solche
maßnahmen auch noch weiterführt um dann
auch zu holen zum durchschnitt sage ich
mal des jeweiligen bundeslandes die
restriktive handhabung bezieht sich
darauf dass es schon bei in einigen
bundesländern eine regelung gab die von
präsenzpflicht und
unterricht ausgegangen ist in den
grundschulen und dass wir uns jetzt
geeinigt haben dass die schulen entweder
geschlossen bleiben
oder aber die präsenzpflicht nicht
stattfindet wir haben festgestellt dass
das sehr also in einer bestimmten
bandbreite sehr unterschiedliche
regelungen gibt und mir war wichtig dass
es jedenfalls ist es mein verständnis
muss man muss jetzt mal sagen dass eben
der der beschluss vom dezember der doch
recht unterschiedlicher variiert
durchgesetzt wurde einheitlicher
durchgesetzt wurde im sinne der
restriktiven länder von denen es im
übrigen ziemlich viele gibt die wir dann
in der abfahrt mit besonderen bleiben
zum beispiel ist wurde aus zürich in den
9.9 steht aus zu betonen dass die länder
mit hotspots ihre regionalen
strukturellen maßnahmen behalten können
natürlich das heißt jetzt beim freistaat
bayern für uns bedeutet auch muss man
sagen der ganze beschluss kaum
änderungen es stimmt wir können aber
unser gesamtes level fortsetzen das
heißt eben ausgangssperren fb2 masken
und dieser doppelte radius das wollte
ich nur mal für die für die bayern sein
wie halten wir natürlich fort weil wir
nach wie vor hohe inzidenz und es ist
nicht nur so dass wir nicht etwas
zurückgenommen haben sondern wir haben
verlängert dass gerade in diesem
schulbereich muss man das mal bewusst
wahrnehmen
bis 14 februar unsere regelung das
bedeutet dass es acht wochen insgesamt
ist acht wochen aus denen wir aus dem
normalen präsenzunterricht wie wir ihn
alle kennen an der schule aussteigen
das keine leichte entscheidung das hat
konsequenzen für die familien für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer für die
schülerinnen und schüler und wenn man
gemeinsam zu so einen beschluss kommt
macht das deutlich wo wir auch den
problemen druck sehen und wie wir
bereits zu handeln in so einem sensiblen
bereich acht worden kristina dunz dem
frau bundeskanzlerin herr söder hat
gerade angesprochen dass es den menschen
jetzt an die substanz geht
das liegt ja auch an dem frust vieler
menschen über die schweren
auseinandersetzungen zwischen bund und
ländern
in diesen fragen jetzt wenn man das
papier heute ließen ihre begründung hier
hört kann man doch nicht davon ausgehen
dass der look down zum 14 februar
gelockert wird sie sagen immer wieder
die maßgabe sind 50 neuinfektionen
300.000 einwohner in den vergangenen
sieben tagen
das alles kann ja bis 14 februar nicht
konsolidiert seien wäre es nicht
ehrlicher den menschen jetzt zu sagen
dass das noch länger anhält und eine
marke zu nennen an der man sich
ausschließlich orientiert die sie ja
auch seit märz vorigen jahres nennen und
den menschen wirklich zu sagen
vierzehnter februar ist nur ein schritt
aber es wird länger dauern das weiß ich
nicht führen gestern haben die die
experten dort gehört auch die
modellierer und der professor nagel von
der technischen universität den wir zum
ersten mal gehört haben hat uns ziemlich
eindringlich gezeigt was die freie
ausweitung dieser mutation bedeuten
könnte mit den maßnahmen mit denen mit
dem wissen was wir heute haben aber hat
es ja noch nicht vollständig das hat
schon nicht gut ausgesehen
aber sie haben uns auch gezeigt dass
wenn wir diese mutation nicht hätten
oder wenn du jetzt diese mutation sehr
früh eindämmen dass wir durchaus eine
chance haben das bohrklein vielleicht
nicht bis ende januar aber im februar
das zu erreichen jetzt machen denn noch
mehr maßnahmen und insofern ist es nicht
richtig dass man sagen kann dass das
außerhalb der reichweite doch ich kann
es mir nicht mit letzter sicherheit
sagen aber die proben die wir da gesehen
haben
waren schon sehr eindeutig dass wenn man
das auf dem weg weiter arbeitet dass das
dann möglich ist wenn sie sich mal
anschauen wir haben jetzt eine ganze
reihe von bundesländern mit 80 88 500
dann welche die so um die 100 liegen
also wir sind in der gesamt incident
sind es wieder um 30 gefallen seit einer
woche also so aussichtslos will ich dass
ich sagen aber es bedarf dann wirklich
auch jetzt einer umfassenden umsetzung
in der home office sache es bedarf eben
nochmal der maßnahmen im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
aber ich würde es nicht beschließen wenn
man sagen müsste das hat überhaupt gar
keine chance ich finde wir müssen uns
doch deshalb habe ich heute das auch mal
gesagt wir müssen doch jetzt auch mal
sagen dass es die weihnachts und
silvesterzeit uns nicht zurückgeworfen
hat sondern sagt wir uns auch auf einen
kurs gebracht hat der durchaus
hoffnungsvoll ist und immer aber was was
wir erwarten müssen und haben will hat
er eben auch auf diesen langen zeitraum
hingewiesen
das ist schon eine große anstrengung
acht wochen mit den schulen und das will
ich überhaupt nicht in abrede stellen
nur wenn wir die verhältnisse von london
hätten
da kann ich nicht finden dann besprechen
wir überhaupt nicht mehr über schulen
sondern sprechen wir über krankenwagen
und überfüllte krankenhäuser und das
muss unbedingt verhindert werden
zwischen diesen beiden polen leben wir
und ich glaube dass wir ehrlich sagen
wenn das alles wirklich gut eingehalten
wird und auch im privaten die menschen
sich an die kontakt beschränkungen
halten dann haben wir eine faire chance
ob wir es erreichen kann ich aber
selbstverständlich nicht 100 prozent
voraussagen
andreas rinke reuters
und es war eine ganz kurze nachfrage
vielleicht kann sich ja mal sagen warum
zwei wochen und nicht vier wochen also
wenn das virus sich doch weiter
ausbreitet warum hat man diesen zeitraum
gewählt und eine frage an die
ministerpräsidenten sie hatten impfen
angesprochen sind denn jetzt eigentlich
nach diesen neuen zusagen von biontech
ihre sorgen was die lieferung bis mitte
februar an geht ausgeräumt oder haben
sie weiter zweifel dass sie eine
ausreichende zugesagte menge bekommen
also das dritte bevölkerungsschutz
gesetz legt schon fest dass wir uns
nicht länger als vier wochen festlegen
dürfen und wir sind heute am 19
januar also wir sind jetzt schon
ziemlich weit gegangen in den februar
hinein das bedeutet also dass wir den
zeit kommen schon ganz gut aus schätzen
wir können nicht beliebig lange die
verordnung machen oder die länder können
nicht beliebig lange die verordnung
machen stoff ist gar nicht so sehr das
entscheidende dann letztendlich die
menge ich glaube da sind wir uns alle
einig dass wir von monat zu monat mehr
bekommen werden mehr lieferungen und das
auch entsprechend entlasten wird in
unserem strategie
das entscheidende ist jetzt gerade in
den ersten wochen die verlässlichkeit
weil das einladungs system ist ja darauf
aufgebaut ich habe jetzt in berlin die
pflegeheime das erst einmal durchgeimpft
die unterschiedlichen altersgruppen
werden jetzt nach und nach angeschrieben
werden eingeladen in das impfzentrum zu
kommen
und natürlich wollen wir dann auch
sicherstellen dass sie eine impfung
bekommen insofern haben wir genau das
heute hinterfragt natürlich ist auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister abhängig von
den lieferungen der unternehmen das ist
gar keine frage aber wir
haben schon eindringlich darum gebeten
dass wir rechtzeitig informiert werden
wann wir mit welchen lieferung rechnen
können weil wir darauf aufbauen und eben
auch entsprechend einladen können gut
läuft das nicht kann man ganz einfach es
ist natürlich ins team nach wie vor zu
wenig impfstoff dann wenn der zugesagte
im stoff dann ausfällt und auch termine
wieder abgesagt werden müssen die erst
mühsam erschlossen würden dann macht es
keinen sehr guten eindruck
das muss man ausdrücklich sagen da kann
aber jetzt auch der bund überhaupt
nichts dafür aber es ist natürlich schon
auch nur rahmen zwei wochen nachdem das
impfen beginnt bereits so was passiert
dann erhöhte ist das grundlegende
vertrauen in die gesamte versorgung in
der nächsten monate also muss man doch
einfach dranbleiben
das sind sie die bemühungen auch
impfstoffe in deutschland zu produzieren
so besonders wichtig denn eines finde
ich muss mein ziel unterstellen aber ich
glaube nicht dass eine produktion
amerika ausfallen wird
das glaube ich jetzt nicht sondern es
schon typisch das ist dann eher aufs
feld aber bietet ist jetzt so deswegen
ist die bemühungen des bundes wirklich
existenziell mehr im stoff in
deutschland zu produzieren
gute nachricht dass die
betriebserlaubnis für marburg jetzt
gegeben wurde und damit kommt mehr
verlässlichkeit wenn wir haben
allerdings mit den pharmazeutischen
verbänden auch gesprochen
in der bundesregierung und man muss
sagen das ist eine hohe logistische
aufgabe und es darf in der lieferkette
keine facette ausfallen und das ist
wirklich von großer strategischer
bedeutung
aber wir sind auf gutem weg und das muss
man auch sagen weil der
gesundheitsminister bereits im august
des vergangenen jahres begonnen hat da
auch unterstützung liefern das land
hessen sehr gut gearbeitet hat und
schnelle genehmigung erteilt hat ja
gesagt für eine kurze letzte frage
michael kufner deutsche welle können sie
nochmal genauer sagen inwieweit die
diskussionen auch stattgefunden haben
und was jemanden nach brüssel mitnehmen
werden bei der frage von mehr
grenzkontrollen oder wo möglichen
erneuten grenzschließungen innerhalb
der eu sehen wir selber von der grund so
besprochen dass gerade die mutation des
virus neu eingetragen werden könnten und
die frage vielleicht auch an herrn söder
da sie hohe instanzen auch an der
bayerischen grenze haben im ausland ja
also wir sehen ja schon ich habe mir zum
beispiel sehr intensiv auch mit dem
österreichischen bundeskanzler
koordiniert die haben jetzt auch noch
mal ihren walk down verlängert
ich habe heute mit dem tschechischen
ministerpräsidenten gesprochen über die
frage wie kann man das regeln wir haben
jetzt zwei dinger das eine ist ja sehr
viele pendler
berufspendler und alle sind wir davon
abhängig die krankenhäuser die
pflegeheime in den verschiedenen
bundesländern die an diese anderen
länder grenzen von deutschland gehen
sehr viele menschen nach luxemburg zum
beispiel arbeite ich habe auch in den
luxemburgischen premierminister
gesprochen und deshalb liegt es an uns
liegt uns natürlich daran einerseits
sicherheit zu haben und deshalb haben
wir drei kategorien die herkunftsgebiete
mutation da müssen wir besonders streng
sein
das gebiet hoch risikogebiet da ist
natürlich zum beispiel die tschechische
republik immer noch sehr hohen incidents
ein land und da ist es dann wichtig dass
man sich koordiniert da muss getestet
werden
da können die menschen die einfach zu
uns kommen und arbeiten bei den
pflegeheimen ist das kein thema weil das
festlich dort sowieso vereinbart ist in
anderen bereichen muss das organisiert
werden da werden wir eine
allgemeinverfügung zu machen weil man
das natürlich miteinander auch
besprechen muss wer testet wo wie was
aber diese tests brauchen wir und wenn
länder ganz andere wege gehen sollten
was ich im moment lese aber das kann
auch sein dann muss man auch bis zu dem
äußersten bereit sein und sagen dann
müssen wir auch wieder grenzkontrollen
einführen das wollen wir nicht wir
wollen uns partnerschaftlich mit unseren
nachbarn einigen aber wir können nicht
zusehen dass dann der eintrag einfach
kommt weil andere länder ganz andere
wege gehen
deshalb war es mir auch sehr wichtig
dass wir heute auch vorlegen und
bestimmte maßnahmen beschließen damit
ich in brüssel auch sagen kann wir
betreiben vorsorge
strategie sehr gut denn da muss was
passieren wir haben aufgrund der
einseitigen quarantäne forderungen etwas
zusätzliches gemacht wer mit seiner wird
es pflicht auch für pendler eingeführt
also weder bei uns is muss auch einmal
die woche sich testen lassen
das ist ganz wichtig weil die einträge
sind bitte ich relativ hoch im
grenzbereich überall spürbar
ich danke ihnen ein gewisses interesse
schon schön ja soweit also die
pressekonferenz von angela merkel
berlins erstem bürgermeister müller und
bayerns ministerpräsident söder die
verkündet haben was wir den abend über
schon teilweise so gehört haben meiner
kollegin nicole diekmann hat das ganze
natürlich auch verfolgt den ganzen abend
schon nikos späth wir wollen das noch
kurz trotzdem versuchen zusammenzufassen
was haben wir da jetzt gerade in kurz
und knackig gehört gut ich habe mir mal
die wichtigsten punkte auf geschrieben
also es wird bis zum 10 februar alles
bisher schon beschlossene verlängert das
was wir unter shutdown hier
zusammenfassen
es bleibt dabei pro haus stand darf man
sich mit einer person treffen die nicht
zum hausstand gehört es wird eine
verschärfte masken pflicht geben das
heißt man darf in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und in geschäften nur
noch medizinische masken tragen und
keine stoffmasken mehr
es wird eine verpflichtung geben das
soll jetzt bundesarbeitsminister heil
umsetzen
für arbeitgeber innen home office zu
ermöglichen das heißt sie müssen
begründen wenn sie das nicht tun
natürlich nur in jobs und berufen in
denen das möglich ist von zu hause aus
zu arbeiten und die schulen sollen zu
bleiben beziehungsweise die
präsenzpflicht soll ausgesetzt werden
und
in altersheimen in pflegeeinrichtungen
und den einrichtungen auch für
behinderte menschen ist das
pflegepersonal verpflichtet im umgang
mit den patientinnen mit den bewohner
innen ffp zwei masken zu tragen das ist
so im groben erstmal das was heute
beschlossen worden ist das interessante
finde ich jetzt nicole das klingt jetzt
alles nicht so krass und überhaupt dass
man denkt so war das ist was völlig
neues ein komplett neuer weg wieso haben
die jetzt so lange dafür gebraucht
man hat sich über das thema schule sehr
gestritten
das haben wir ja auch schon während des
mitbekommen man hat unterdessen eine
pause eingelegt weil man sich nicht
einig wurde die linie das kanzleramt ist
die linie von angela merkel war die
schulen dicht zu machen
es gab mehrere länder die dagegen waren
die entweder gesagt haben wir wollen
präsenzunterricht dann im wechsel modell
weiter ermöglichen oder aber das war
wohl die position von mecklenburg
vorpommern die gesagt haben bis zum 15
februar das ist uns eigentlich zu lang
an diesem punkt hat man sich anscheinend
sehr sehr lange aufgehalten
nach dem was wir jetzt gerade auf der
pressekonferenz dieser drei gehört haben
von angela merkel markus söder und
michael müller hat sich das kanzleramt
mit seiner linie durchgesetzt können wir
davon ausgehen dass diese linie die sich
dort jetzt abzeichnet die sie verkündet
haben tatsächlich auch durchgezogen
würde ich meine wir haben das ja schon
öfter erlebt da wird was verkündet und
wenn die verordnung und kommen der
bundesländer dann fehlt das eine oder
andere ja wir können davon ausgehen das
ist nicht überall so umgesetzt wird
während diese pressekonferenz gerade
noch lief und nochmal viel die rede von
einigkeit war und auch begründet wurde
warum man es so wichtig findet aller
gegenargumente zum trotz die schulen
geschlossen zu halten floppte hier auf
meinem computer die eilmeldung auf
wonach der baden württembergische
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
von den grünen kretschmann
entschuldigung von den grünen gerade an
nicht habe in seinem bundesland würden
vom ersten februar an kitas und schulen
wieder schrittweise geöffnet das heißt
er hat während diese pressekonferenz
lief das was da gesagt wurde kontaktiert
für den hinterkopf vielleicht keine ganz
und interessante info mitte märz wird in
baden württemberg gewählt
das spannende ist wir haben gleich
jammer stammen noch hier bei uns im
stream das ist gesundheits der
gesundheitsexperte der grünen bündnis 90
die grünen das ist die partei von
winfried kretschmann das heißt da werde
ich gleich mal fragen was da jetzt los
dass bei den grünen warum die ausscheren
während das eine schon noch verkündet
wird aber vielleicht noch mal an dich
ich gucke hier die ganze zeit auch in
unsere kommentare und wir haben
natürlich viele zuschauerinnen die auch
studieren oder ausbildung machen und an
berufsschulen und dieses die ganze zeit
fragen was ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit
meiner ausbildung das ist in meinen
abschlussprüfungen
wie finden diese statt wo sie da
irgendwas zugesagt man wirklich das auch
weiß wo es langgeht
nein es tut mir wirklich leid wir hatten
das ja vor ich weiß nicht 14 stunden als
wir das erste mal miteinander gesprochen
haben
also spaß beiseite wir haben das ja
heute abend schon einmal besprochen wie
wir heute schon ein paar mal live auch
diesmal ist das thema universitäten ist
auch das thema berufsschulen mit keiner
silbe erwähnt worden auch nicht in der
beschlussvorlage so dass man jetzt
vielleicht sagen könnte man wollte die
pressekonferenz nach diesen mehr als
sieben stunden verhandlungen jetzt nicht
unnötig in die länge ziehen weil es gibt
kein keine informationen dazu
das ist ja schon ein bisschen merkwürdig
vielleicht sollten wir doch tatsächlich
auch mal nachhaken weil das betrifft
auch viele leute die gerade jetzt sich
fragen was passiert jetzt mit meiner
ausbildung schulen kitas klar sind
wichtig da sind junge menschen betroffen
die zu hause beaufsichtigt werden müssen
berufsschulen universitäten die können
schon auf sich selber aufpassen trotzdem
würden natürlich gerne wissen wie es
weitergeht
wie geht es denn jetzt überhaupt weiter
da ist jetzt was verkündet worden
das geht ja wahrscheinlich wie immer
nicht ab sofort sondern wir müssen
darauf warten dass die länder das in
neue verordnungen gießen oder die länder
müssen diese beschlüsse jetzt umsetzen
genau und wie wir gehört haben bis
einschließlich 14 februar soll das jetzt
gelten bis auf die home office pflicht
die soll bis zum 15 märz gelten da hat
man jetzt in längeren zeitraum für
veranschlagt das heißt man wird sich
vorher wieder treffen jetzt ist die
frage wann das treffen heute ist ja
vorgezogen worden
das war eigentlich für vier für die
folgende für nächste woche veranschlagt
worden
der grund dafür dass man sich jetzt eine
fast eine woche früher getroffen hat das
hat angela merkel gesagt und zwar ich
habe es mir aufgeschrieben
eine minute nach beginn der
pressekonferenz das zeigt die
dringlichkeit der grund dafür dass man
sich jetzt heute schon getroffen hat und
der meinung war man müsse da noch mal
ran und verschärfen in welchem maß auch
immer das ist die mutierte variante des
virus
deswegen ist jetzt schwer zu sagen wenn
man sich das nächste mal trifft also auf
jeden fall rechtzeitig vom 14 februar
wenn dann die maßnahmen die heute
beschlossen wurde sind auslaufen würden
ich schaue noch mal in unsere kommentare
da gibt es fragen zu der neuen masten
pflicht also der pflicht zum tragen von
medizinischen masken zum beispiel einmal
die frage warum die medizinischen masken
nur in läden und im öffentlichen yamaha
oder öffentlichen personenverkehr
getragen werden müssen und nicht überall
da wurde ja überhaupt nicht darauf
eingegangen
vielmehr überall gibt es ja inzwischen
nicht mehr also das ist das sind eben
die räume das sind die das sind halt die
orte wo man menschen noch nahe kommt
fremden menschen die ihren job wenn man
sich an die regeln hält noch mehr den
ist quasi auf baustellen geben in
betrieben in büros da ist noch ein
bisschen luft oder naja da es ja
wiederum die strategie das zu entzerren
indem man eben home office anbietet man
da wurde aber eben auch darauf
hingewiesen
wenn man sich zu nah kommt dann soll man
eben auch ffp zwei masken oder
medizinische masken tragen
da ist es aber natürlich auch
schwieriger das zu kontrollieren es ist
eine sache beim bäcker einmal zu schauen
ob da die kunden auch wirklich
medizinische masken tragen und natürlich
auch im öffentlichen personennahverkehr
das ist ein eklatanter unterschied aber
wie gesagt es gibt nicht mehr so viel
anderes es gibt keine konzerte es gibt
keine kinos die offen sind in denen man
sich den film angucken kann bevor wir
schon ein bisschen fast vergessen dass
es so was mal gab früher noch eine frage
die auch immer wieder aufkam
tatsächlich war es die zwei masten sind
nicht umsonst die sind relativ
kostspielig
die frage hier von château rubine auf
youtube gibt es denn geld wenn man sich
fb2 nicht leisten kann oder werden die
ich vielleicht wie das ja auch schon mal
der fall war
jetzt im winter an bedürftige kostenlos
verteilte haben ja senioren ein paar
bekommen tja das ist eine frage die kann
ich leider nicht beantworten arbeitgeber
innen sollen ffp zwei masten an ihre
mitarbeiter innen verteilt so das ist
dann eine hoffnung die frage ist auch
haben wir überhaupt noch kapazitäten
dafür darauf wurde ein gegangen ich habe
es nicht so wirklich gehört oder hast du
das gehört dazu ich habe es auch nicht
gehört aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass
man davon ausgeht dass man die
kapazitäten hat es wäre eine riesige
blamage
ich will das nicht ausschließen dass es
kommt aber es wäre eine riesige blamage
wenn man jetzt diese anordnung hier
verkündet und dann ist der markt
leergefegt das wäre ein großes problem
ja aber mit großen problemen haben wir
ja doch die letzten monate immer wieder
zu tun gehabt
nicole ich würde sagen die schicken wir
den feierabend das war ein langer tag
für dich aber wir sind noch nicht ganz
fertig ich möchte gern noch sprechen mit
janosch dahmen den gesundheitsexperten
von bündnis 90 die grünen der auch mit
uns ausgeharrt hat sich die beschlüsse
angehört hat und die jetzt hoffentlich
zugeschaltet ist ich schaue mal
ach richtig ihr zweiter vorher nochmal
für alle die das nochmal quasi in kurz
und schriftlich brauchen eine kleine
zusammenfassung meinem kollegen michael
conrad die bisherigen beschlüsse von
bund und ländern gelten fort und zwar
erst einmal bis zum 14 februar private
treffen sind weiterhin im kreis der
angehörigen des eigenen hausstandes und
mit einer weiteren nicht im haushalt
lebenden personen gestattet
die zahl der haushalte aus der die
weiteren personen kommen soll möglichst
klein gehalten werden
die massen pflicht den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln sowie in geschäften wird
konkretisiert es müssen medizinische
masken getragen werden entweder eine f e
p2 maske oder op maske das gilt jetzt
auch für das personal in alten und
pflegeheimen schulen und kitas bleiben
geschlossen es soll aber weiter eine
notbetreuung geben fällt die sieben tage
incidents unter 50 ist eine schrittweise
öffnung geplant home office wird
verpflichtend dort wo es möglich ist
ja also das sind die beschlüsse für die
die bundes die bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten der länder heute
relativ lange gebraucht haben und
darüber möchte ich es nochmal reden mit
janosch dahmen bündnis 90/die grünen
bundestagsabgeordneter und
gesundheitsexperte einen schönen guten
abend herr damen genannt so wir haben es
gerade gehört der große knackpunkt war
die frage wie lange sollen schulen und
kitas geschlossen bleiben oder zumindest
keine präsenzpflicht mehr haben
frau merkel hat gerade angekündigt in
berlin dass das bis zum vierzehnten
tiroler fall sein soll da ist ihr
parteikollege winfried kretschmann der
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
ausgeschert und hat gesagt er will ab
den ersten zweiten wieder schrittweise
auf machen ist das eine gute idee
ich habe ja zusammen mit ihnen hier vor
der pressekonferenz ausgeharrt so dass
ich zu allen details der ankündigung aus
baden württemberg jetzt auch nicht sagen
kann aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden
habe war der wortlaut so dass man wenn
es die infektion logische lage zulässt
dann prüfen will ob ab anfang februar
die schulen wieder aufmachen können oder
die kitas wieder aufmacht
können ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt als
arzt und auch als politiker der diese
paniert in den letzten wochen und
monaten sehr intensiv verfolgt hat nicht
richtig vorstellen wie sich die
infektiologe lage in den kommenden tagen
so sehr entspannt sollte das dann in
baden württemberg die bedingungen eine
lockerung zu lassen aber wenn das
gelingt dann ist natürlich das ist ja
auch auf der pressekonferenz von der
bundeskanzlerin und dem regierenden
bürgermeister von berlin gesagt worden
bildung das wichtigste gut und dann
sollte natürlich schule oder kita als
allererstes möglich gemacht werden aber
noch einmal herr kortmann verrat
kretschmann verspricht zu viel was er
wahrscheinlich halten kann
naja er sagt er knüpft die bedingung
dass schulen und kitas aufmachen können
an eine besserung der infektiologe
schlage wo ist der wortlaut gewesen und
auch die dann eingetreten wird das muss
ich noch unter beweis stellen
aber was ist das für signal wenn in
berlin gesagt wird wir sollten das
geschlossen halten das wurde stundenlang
darum gerungen und noch während das
gesagt wird geht eine
ministerpräsidentin dieser nach vorne
und sagt wenn ich kann mache ich aber
vorher auf also nochmal ich spreche
jetzt nicht für das land baden
württemberg und ich kann es im detail
die gründe die ja dort im
kultusministerium sicherlich auch wohl
durchdacht worden sind nicht vertreten
oder im detail nachvollziehen aber im
kern so zu sagen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe ist die kopplung dieses
wichtigen gut bildungs immer noch unter
dem vorbehalt einer infektion logischen
besserung und die muss ich eben erst
unter beweis stellen
ja aber trotzdem richtig einig sieht das
ganze nicht aus vielleicht rufen sie
nachher januar an und fragen weil
winfried was war das denn jetzt
eigentlich für eine geschichte gucken
wir mal auf diese masken pflicht die
viele menschen hier interessieren er
fährt mit zwei masken sollen jetzt
verpflichtend werden in öffentlichen
nahverkehr in öffentlichen transporten
also auch in der bahn und in geschäften
kommt das nicht ein bisschen spät
vielleicht oder hätte man das nicht
schon früher machen können
absolut das thema masken ist ein ganz
wichtiges es ist für mich als arzt auch
unverständlich warum die matten pflicht
jetzt nicht auf sichere zwei masten
eingegrenzt wurde sondern
dieses weite feld und undefinierte feld
medizinischer masken was ja gar kein
definierter geschützter begriff ist
ausgeweitet wurde so dass da auch wieder
sehr viele abweichungen möglich sind die
tatsächlich nicht den schutz bieten den
wir angesichts der sehr gefährlichen
neuen mutationen leuchten wie sicher
sind denn diese op masken das ist ja
eigentlich wenn man die mal so anfasst
fühlt es sich eher an wie so ein
bisschen papier also es gibt ja auch da
am markt sehr unterschiedliche ganz
wichtig ist ähnlich wie bei dfb zwei
masten dass die sehr eng und adäquat
getragen werden müssen dass sie greifen
die sind wenn es tatsächlich echte
medizinische masten sind tatsächlich
besser als die ein oder andere schlecht
sitzender alltags maske aber die haben
lange nicht den schutz den fv 2 machten
haben und das war ja die neue
gefahrenlage vor dem hintergrund dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute
stattgefunden hat dass wir mit der
mutation ein sehr viel ansteckendes
virus haben was uns im moment hier in
deutschland wer bedroht
was würden sie denn sagen jetzt
schlussendlich es hat lange gedauert was
dort beschlossen wurde sind diese
beschlüsse die es verkündet wurden
tatsächlich der wurf der uns aus der
pandemie tragen kann
um ehrlich zu sein ist die lücke
zwischen den empfehlungen die die
wissenschaft und ja auch das rk ii
vorher gegeben hat und dem was dann
jetzt politik getroffen hat sehr groß
ich kann sicherlich erkennen dass man
sich konsequent dazu verabredet hat
fortzusetzen was ohnehin schon geheilt
aber ich kann das mögliche mehr an
schutz was jetzt notwendig gewesen wäre
nicht erkennen wir hatten das thema fb2
machten ja schon angesprochen aber das
ist ja nicht das einzige ich vermisse
zum beispiel dass wir weiterhin keine
schnellte strategie haben schnelltest
für den eigengebrauch werden ganz
wichtige ergänzung gewesen
um hier mehr sicherheit zu bekommen und
ich kann draußen soll ich immer das
können amateure gar nicht richtig
durchführen oder das ist inzwischen
sowohl durch neuere generationen von
tests als auch entsprechende belege aus
der wissenschaft eigentlich anders
gezeigt also mit guter anleitungen sind
sowohl die konventionellen stellt es die
schon auf dem markt sind als auch die
neue generation von schnelltests sehr
viel
einfach durchführbar sind und jetzt in
österreich flächendeckend auch in
schulen eingesetzt werden durchaus
durchführbar und hier wäre es dringend
an der zeit gewesen dass auch für den
eigengebrauch und für den
flächendeckenden einsatz zuzulassen
was halten sie von dieser home office
regelung die jetzt gerade verkündet
wurde also das ist quasi eine man kann
nicht wirklich seine pflicht aber die
verarbeitung arbeitgeber müssen sich
schon rechtfertigen wenn sie keinen home
office zu lassen die arbeitnehmer soll
es bitte wahrnehmen ist es der richtige
weg oder gegen das für das noch strenger
gehen also die verordnung zum home
office ist sicher richtig entscheidend
wird dabei sein wie effektiv die jetzt
in der formulierung und auch umsetzung
ist das muss schnell passieren
wir haben hier super viel zeit verloren
und das hätte längst die arbeitswelt in
die schutzstrategien viel mehr
einbezogen werden müssen
ich habe noch große sorgen dass am ende
letztlich eine formulierung herauskommt
die sehr weich ist und eher den
charakter eines appells hat und in der
praxis dann im alltag nur ganz wenig
erinnert faktisch ist es ja so es gibt
viele menschen die gerne zu hause
arbeiten würden das auch möglich machen
aber ganz viele betriebe die das nach
wie vor nicht vorsehen und auch
dezidiert untersagen da muss jetzt
dringend was passieren weil die
mobilität im kontext arbeit ist viel zu
hoch
jetzt gibt es aber hier auch stimmen bei
uns in der zuschauerschaft die zum
beispiel sagen hat sich mal jemand
gedanken gemacht wie home office und
gleichzeitig unterrichten der kinder
funktionieren soll
andere bemerkung dann darunter
notbetreuung also in schulen und kitas
ohne strenge kriterien das ist
lächerlich die einrichtungen sind zum
teil richtig voll gut da sind jetzt zwei
sachen das heißt als er einmal gibt es
kein richtig strengen kriterien wäre
jetzt nicht betreten darf und das andere
mal dass wenn die kinder zu hause hat
wird es aber wirklich schwierig mit home
office und kinderbetreuung parallel das
heißt für eltern werden die nächsten
vier bis acht wochen überhaupt nicht
lustig absolut ich bin selber vater
zweier kleiner kinder und ich weiß wie
schwierig schule und betreuung auch
zuhause zu organisieren ist ich will das
auch gar nicht klein reden und es wird
sicherlich so sein das ist auch im
einzelfall einfach schlichtweg nicht
funktioniert und also ist einfach
bedeutet zu sagen wir werden in dieser
schwierigen und
wichtigen zeit der pandemie nicht im
vollen umfang arbeitsleben weiter
fortführen können wie das außerhalb der
partie wie möglich ist so dass an
stellen wo man sagen muss hier geht die
kinderbetreuung vor
man auch teile der arbeit wird
zurückstellen müssen da führt kein weg
dran vorbei
bezüglich der betreuung der kinder da
spreche ich mich sehr dafür aus dort wo
wirklich betreuung erforderlich ist das
mag zum einen für wichtige berufe der
fall sein es kann aber auch im
einzelfall soziale gründe seien nicht
das erforderlich machen halte ich so
eine betreuungsgarantie weiter für
richtig aber es darf natürlich nicht so
sein dass der eindruck entsteht auch
jeder kann wie er will sein kind
schicken
dann kommen wir nicht weiter wir wissen
dass leider auch kinder und jugendliche
zur verbreitung des virus mit beitragen
gerade auch bei der neuen virus variante
scheint es da hinweise zu geben dass das
ein problem sein kann und das müssen wir
sehr ernst nehmen sonst nicht
funktionieren
jetzt gibt es ja dringender appelle aus
der aus den kreisen der wissenschaft zum
beispiel von frau prise man die jedoch
sehr renommiert ist die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um zu sagen
wir brauchen eigentlich einen kompletten
harten locker und alles was nicht
dringend benötigt wird muss schließen
für drei bis vier wochen am besten
europaweit damit dass wir uns hier
wirklich also gut die ausrotten konnten
quasi eine einer zero kowitz strategie
davon ist überhaupt nicht die rede in
deutschland auch nicht in ihrer partei
warum wird dieser vorschlag nicht ernst
genommen ich kann jetzt nicht für meine
ganze partei sprechen aber ich kann für
mich ganz persönlich als arzt und auch
als jemand der seit vielen wochen sich
extrem ernst mit dieser pandemie
bekämpfung auseinandersetzt sagen das
was drauf diese man vertritt ist ja
keine strategie von tatsächlich 0 kobelt
sondern zu sagen wir müssen in einen
bereich kommen von unter zehn
neuerkrankungen ab 1000 wo wir die
pandemie bewältigen können und dass das
absolut richtig ich sage es nochmal ich
bin von den entschlossen heute
enttäuscht ich hätte mir da deutlich
mehr konsequenz über das geltende maß
hinaus erwartet in allen säulen der
panini bekämpfung im übrigen jetzt nicht
nur was sichere schutzmaßnahmen oder
schnelltasten angeht sondern auch beim
thema impfen auch hier finden sich in
den beschlüssen keine klaren vorgaben
das continium wie man das schneller
voranbringen will und wenn man sich
anschaut laufen da die ihnen strategien
ja auch in den ländern teilweise sehr
auseinander wo wir auf einen weiten ende
haben die es durchaus geschafft haben
einen großen teil älterer menschen zu
impfen und andere die überwiegend
jüngere beispielsweise aus dem
medizinischen personal geimpft haben was
auch wichtig ist aber uns bei dem
entlastungen des gesundheitswesen und
der vermeidung von todeszahlen noch
nicht so weit hilft wie es aktuell
brauche das heißt konkret auf ihre frage
geantwortet ja also die fälle runter
bekommen auf ein sehr niedriges niveau
das werden wir nur mit sehr konsequenten
sehr entschlossenen maßnahmen erreichen
und es war allerhöchste zeit dass jetzt
konsequent zu tun das heißt die politik
in berlin und alle parteien die jetzt
gerade in regierungsverantwortung sind
ja auch teile von ihrer partei sind dazu
mutlos ich spreche grundsätzlich niemand
in regierungsverantwortung frei auch
nicht die grünen ich habe auch in allen
statements der vergangenen wochen gesagt
das ist eine geteilte verantwortung von
bund und ländern
ich habe die bundeskanzlerin in den
letzten wochen und auch monaten immer
wieder als der konsequent und fordernd
in der position und auch wahrnehmung der
gefahr erlebt und es wäre gut gewesen
hätte man dieses mahnung an dem einen
oder anderen punkt früher aufgegriffen
ganz konkret haben wir mit der mutation
hier jetzt eine neue bedrohungslage und
ich hätte mir ausdrücklich gewünscht
auch von grün regierten ländern dass wir
hier heute zu noch konsequenteren
schlüssen gekommen werden
jetzt habe ich hier eine frage die es
tatsächlich auch für ihre partei ich
würde fast sagen eine gretchenfrage
vielleicht gucken wir die uns noch mal
kurz an von serena ist auf youtube über
80 millionen masken op maßen und fsb
zwei masten so viele deckwerk artikel
die teilweise jetzt nicht wo du die
heraus aber immer zur kenntnis dass es
viele sind einfach es ist auch die
umwelt unserer kinder und kindeskinder
wir produzieren eh schon zu viel will
nicht noch mehr
das ist ja doch ein thema was ihnen in
der grünen partei bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr am herzen liegt dass nicht zu viel
müll produziert wird wir produzieren
hier viele wegwerfartikel wie gehen sie
damit um
also grundsätzlich geht es ja dabei
immer um die frage der
rohstoffverwaltung und der
weiterverwertung grundsätzlich ist
müll dann schlimm wenn wir dinge
eigentlich nur verbrennen und nicht in
eine weiterverwendung und fortführung
bringen im bereich der medizin ich kenne
aus als arzt aus vielen jahren aus dem
krankenhaus ist es auch bei stoffen die
in bereichen zum einsatz kommen wo wir
sehr vorsichtig sind inzwischen so das
ist sehr sehr gute
aufbereitungsverfahren gibt und es gibt
jetzt prinzipiell keine sorge dass wir
durch den einsatz von masken rohstoffe
in einer art und weise verbrauchen die
wir danach auch nicht anders weiter
verwenden gut dass werden aber ja ich
sag mal ganz normale amateure und
menschen die hat damit auf der straße
rumlaufen hier so nicht machen können
wie das in einem professionellen greis
seitlichen kreislauf system in einem
krankenhaus der fall ist da sicherlich
richtig und ich sicher noch mal ein
guter punkt die frage zu stellen wie
können wir hier auch nachhaltiger
umgehen inzwischen gibt es ja ganz gute
anleitung auch darüber dass es nicht so
ist dass man die maske mit einmal tragen
direkt wegwerfen muss sondern wenn man
sie sieben tage bei raumluft zur seite
legt das dann sozusagen die viren
absterben und die maske dann durchaus
noch mal verwendet werden kann
im kern ist es natürlich so dass in
einer so schwierigen zeit vor einer so
großen gefahren der wir stehen im moment
sehr genau gucken müssen wo können wir
durch welchen ressourcen ein platzwart
schützen aber klar dieses virus ist wenn
wir uns anschauen und auf seine
entstehung und ursprung zurück schauen
ist entstanden an stellen wo mensch mit
natur und umwelt nicht gut umgegangen
ist also angefangen von den märkten in
ostasien wo das auf den vier märkten
aufgetreten ist über nerzfarm in
dänemark wo es zuletzt mutiert und
aufgetreten ist all das sollte uns zu
denken geben und sicherlich auch in der
entstehung solcher viren uns dazu
veranlassen im umgang mit natur und
umwelt und rohstoffen in einem umdenken
zu kommen ja da mit vielen dank dass sie
heute abend ausgeharrt haben und noch
rede und antwort gestanden haben zu
diesem schwierigen thema auch für ihre
partei und ich bedanke mich bei euch für
das lange durchhalten fürs zuschauen für
eure fragen und kommentare wir machen
das jetzt mal hier langsam zu ich freue
mich aber wenn ihr lust habt mal wieder
dabei zu sein wenn im livestream lasst
uns doch bitte in guter alter youtube
oder
es bot man ihr ein like und ein abo da
in der zdf- heute- app geht das leider
noch nicht aber da arbeiten wir
vielleicht auch noch dran
trotzdem freuen wir uns denn ihr zb da
die push benachrichtigungen einschaltet
dann verpasst ihr keinen livestream und
keine wichtige entwicklung alle weiteren
informationen auch zum beispiel darüber
wie man mit diesen ffb zwei masten am
besten umgeht also wie man die wieder
verwerten kann haben wir für euch auf
zdf heute.de oder in der zdf- heute- app
oder auf unseren diversen anderen social
media kanälen zum beispiel auf instagram
da könnt ihr uns auch ein abo
hinterlassen da gibt es dann auch jeden
tag die neuesten news für heute das sage
ich aber vielen dank fürs zu sehen für
die aufmerksamkeit und ich sag dann mal
dass zum nächsten mal wurden zum
beispiel da wird neuer us präsident
vereidigt da sind wir wieder für euch da
bis dahin macht's gut